- [Mark] Regina, so where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in the Nickerson Gardens.
- [Mark] Which is the?
- [Regina] Which is the
projects and the Bounty Hunters.
I was a runaway.
I left my family 'cause I was hot headed.
- [Mark] At what age?
- [Regina] At 12.
- [Mark] At 12? Wow.
- Yeah, and I started
drinking, and partying,
and mixing.
I started doing things that wasn't...
That I didn't grew up...
That I knew better than doing.
But eventually, the fight
started coming because
I was young and girls was jealous
because I was younger than them,
and I was prettier than them.
Or because I had more attention.
But then, I think I liked it that
I had to start fighting,
because it made me,
who I am today.
My struggle made me strong.
- [Mark] What...
So, you've done prison time?
- I've been imprisoned-
I went to prison at the age of 18.
I escaped from Sybil Brand
1995. October 1st, 1995.
I was the first...
Me and Rebecca Dahl was the
first two individuals to
ever escape Sybil Brand.
It was scaring me.
I didn't know nothing about prison.
I thought I would to go to
prison and be somebody bitch.
So, I escaped from Sybil Brand.
- [Mark] Wait. What is Sybil Brand?
- It's the county jail for women.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- It was on the news. If you
Google it, you would see.
- [Mark] So you escaped from prison?
- Yeah, I escaped from there.
I was on the news.
America's most wanted.
You know the features:
"Have you seen this person?"
They caught me 32 days later.
They caught her the next day.
I did my first prison term at 18.
I'm 42 years old.
I've got, no, I don't have 10.
I have 13 prison terms.
One strike.
I be down here since I was 13.
I've worked the streets.
I've done a little bit
of everything down here.
- [Mark] Tell me about
you parents, growing up.
- My parents, my mother was a addict,
and my dad, I stayed with my dad,
but I always wanted my mom.
But my mom was on her drugs and stuff.
And the last time I remember having my mom
when she was on the patio
naked, she was on her PCP.
And she had a trick down on her throat.
She couldn't talk.
And my dad took me from her,
and my dad,
he was a (stutters).
He was a addict himself,
but he was more a functional addict.
But then things got out of hand
and him and his current wife got into it,
so he left me with my grandmother.
My grandmother was a church goer, so
she didn't keep up with me that much.
She just-
I just did what I wanted to do.
You know, disregard her.
But yeah, I would find
myself on the streets.
After the gang bang, that's when
I left Nickerson Garden
because it got too much.
I headed to Bill Barton's.
I started working the
streets at Bill Barton's
at the age of 14.
And I raped.
I remember getting raped.
And um, that slowed- (knocking).
That slowed me down a little bit.
I eventually got with somebody older.
He was things,
Norman Boosac.
He was 40, I was 15,
and we came down here and
that's when I started...
Came down here and I started selling drugs
and gang-banging more.
And then we went back to Compton.
That's when I became...
I'm from South side, I'm actually a Crip.
I grew up with the Bloods but I...
So then I started selling drugs down here.
When I started selling drugs down here,
I was making lots of money.
I was making so much money,
but my mother ended up dying.
When mother ended up dying,
I ended up, started using cocaine.
- [Mark] So you were
selling but not using?
- I was selling but not using.
When I was younger,
I was smoking weed, PCP, but never crack.
I started excusing last,
to became my best customer.
- [Mark] You became your best customer?
- (laughs)
I became my best customer.
I ended up losing a lot of people
I thought meant something to me,
but I didn't care. My mother was gone.
I wanted to be numb.
Started working the streets again.
(indistinct background noise)
And my...
And I started...
I started changing because Downtown you.
People bring things out of you
that you don't want to...
That you didn't know that was there.
(indistinct background chattering)
This got me thinking. (laughs)
Next question.
- [Mark] Living Downtown's
a trip, isn't it?
- Downtown is...
It's actually I've been down here...
14. I've been down here almost 30 years.
- [Mark] 30 years?
What's the craziest thing
you've seen down here?
- The craziest thing I've
seen when I seen a woman
get pushed out the frontier window.
I seen a woman, two people actually.
The frontier.
I was outside hustling.
- [Mark] Which floor?
- I don't know what floor she came from
but she came...
Cause I was outside and it was like, bam.
I've never seen nothing like that.
I was in the Cecil and the girl,
she jumped, she jumped.
They say she jumped
but I don't think she jumped. Room 742.
She fell but she lived.
- [Mark] She lived?
- She lived for two days
and when she turned
herself she could fell.
And when she fell, she turned herself
over and she was saying, "Please, Lord.
Please don't let me die.
Please let me live long." Tell him.
I don't know if she...
I think she may have told
it, but she ended up dying.
But she lived two days after the seventh.
The Cecil.
I don't know if you know where
to stay in on maintenance.
That seventh floor is high.
- [Mark] Very.
- Yeah. That was one of the
craziest things I've seen.
- [Mark] (indistinct)
No, not actually.
The man that got caught on fire.
That set on fire not too long ago.
That was the craziest thing I've seen.
Yeah.
- [Mark] You've seen it all.
- (laughs) I haven't seen...
I've seen enough.
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
- I have seven kids.
- [Mark] Seven kids?
- I have.
I didn't become a mother until I had
my last baby boy.
I've had drug-related babies.
My daughter, she won a
scholarship for Beating The Odds.
She's...
She's a nurse now.
She graduated St. Mary's.
She's the best part of me.
She overcame all this,
her mama leaving her.
I left her in the hospital
when she a preemie
to go get high.
I had the staples in my
stomach and I left the hospital
with staples in my stomach to
come down here and get high.
And my baby wasn't doing better.
But I have seven kids
and I want another one actually.
- [Mark] But the last one you're raising?
- The last one I'm raising,
but right now he stays with my cousin
because I had went to prison
and I had my son with me.
That's the only one I raised,
but I went to prison for sales
and my cousin...
I gave my cousin temporary guardianship
and I don't want him back down here, so
I'm trying to get me together
so I can get my baby back.
I've been clean for
five months, three days.
- [Mark] Good for you.
How do you...
how do you get clean from crack?
- I got clean from crack
by smoking crystal.
I weighed myself off crack.
- [Mark] I've been through that before.
- I did that.
And then now I don't smoke.
I don't have the taste for crystal no more
because I look at everybody and they start
picking their face.
I see certain people and they're...
They're delusional and
I don't want to be that.
I've been...
I've done a lot out here and I want...
I thank God that my brain is still
somewhat.
- [Mark] (giggles) Exactly.
- So I just take one day at a time.
I'll say today, just for
today, I won't get high.
So tomorrow when I wake up
I'll say just for today, I won't get high.
- [Mark] That's very good.
- So...
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's great.
That's nice to hear.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's rare.
- Yeah. I've gone through a time
in my life where I down here,
I've lost my baby thought...
People think that I had
told on somebody down here.
So it's like...
But where I come from,
you're not supposed to...
You're supposed to have
proof on something like that
instead of just put a pin in that on down.
So I had to go prove
myself to a lot of people
that I didn't do what they thought I did.
And it made me realize
that they was never my friend
at all in the first place.
So I'm separating myself.
- [Mark] So your kids,
how many different dads?
- Oh, all of them have different dads.
- [Mark] Seven kids, seven dads.
- I have seven...
Six baby daddies, seven kids.
I have a set of twins.
I have...
And actually...
Actually my son, my last
baby, his dad is in prison.
And my husband, I had met, we
got married three years ago.
He's in prison right now.
He helped me raise my son.
He'd adopted my son.
They tried to take my baby
and everything when I was in prison.
But he put a stop to that.
His name is Life, my baby.
I have, yeah, a lot of baby daddies.
Probably would have more kids.
I've had two abortions.
- [Mark] What are your kids' names?
- Christopher is 26.
Ronisha's 24. She'll be 25.
Reality is 19.
Forever is 17.
Asia and Isaiah is 15.
Amira is 12 and...
No, Amira's 13.
And Life is six.
- [Mark] What would you say to them
if you could talk to
them, all (indistinct).
- If I could tell them right now,
I would tell them I apologize for
not being there for you.
For missing out on all the time that
you needed me to be there.
If it's not too late, I
hope we can be friends.
Get to know each other.
It's not a day that goes by that
I don't think of you
and wonder how you look.
I wonder if you thinking of me
like I'm thinking about you.
But I never forget you a smile.
I never forget your smell.
I always...
I love to smell my babies
when they was born,
but I love you guys.
And hopefully we can
be a family again.
- [Mark] Being clean is the first step.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's great
that you're doing that.
- I get clean.
- [Mark] Thank you so
much for talking to me.
- Thank you.